the Joe Rogan experience that's a great
thing about ESPN including with the UFC
is that so many sports fans just have
ESPN on automatic absolutely like I was
at a pool hall on Saturday night I did a
show in Baltimore and then we went to a
pool hall we got there right when junior
was entering into the Octagon it was
perfect yeah it's perfect timing and I
was like don't blink
cuz this [ __ ] probably ain't gonna
make it out of the first round yeah that
was that was a fight I was telling my
grandmother about that fight now like
I'm not I'm not pushing you she was a
it's interesting like Francis wants
another shot at the title and you know
it's it's uh I mean I don't know why
they wouldn't give him another shot
style I've in my opinion it's like what
you got now is steep a vs. DC that that
irons out who's the champ right and
thank God they made that fight instead
of the Brock Lesnar fight I mean I think
the Brock Lesnar fight would have been
fun and I want
I love DC I want him to get paid I think
he sends Brock Lesnar into another
dimension that's what I think happens in
that fight and I think he gets a big
payday and that's all great but the
reality is the real fight steep a steep
a is the most successful UFC heavyweight
champion of all time the only guy to
ever defend the title four times and the
only guy to survived the [ __ ]
hurricane that is Francis and gone yeah
the only guy yeah he figured it out he
figured it out just weather the storm
you know just roll with the punches kick
the legs jab move usual wrestling and
wrestle I mean anybody had to stop he
had to avoid the punches at first yeah
and he's got you know that wasn't
interesting to - I was thinking the
fight with disty pay with Francis how
much did that take out a steep a cuz
even though he won that fight when DC
knocked him out with one punch like wow
that's crazy you don't see steep a
getting knocked out like that I wonder
if he was still suffering from the in
Ghana fight which is only like a few
months before that I don't know if he
was still suffering from that versus um
it's perfect punch - yeah that's that's
the thing um and DC talked about it he
talked about we saw this being an option
in this fight this being an opportunity
to get this tool and this shot there's
he did it you know that that's the thing
if Francis anybody probably anybody with
any power of course if Francis lands
that shots it's night lights out also
yeah but um he didn't see you and he
didn't he didn't have the skillset to
provide that opportunity Ronnie you know
I think that's that that might be more
telling this sort of perfect punch to
him you know he he gets rid of the arm
on the left side then boom the right
hand comes over you got like that that
kind of thing that makes me appreciate
like fight IQ of a guy like Cormier no I
mean because like again and got a bigger
puncher like but like he just doesn't
have the skillset that DC has and seeing
that like you remember him talking about
that in the post fight you know like
that was something they saw and to to
know that that's there and find that
opportunity to make that opportunity
happen you know that's um
that's high level stuff man that was
tough that's what the best guys do I
heard that DC looks fantastic in camp I
heard it looks so good but I'm really
interested to see what a motivated
hungry you know out for revenge deep a
can do and like he mean he knows to take
that away yeah you know what I mean is
DC he kind of got into it he explained
exactly what they saw and how they
figured to use that against him so like
Steve Hays also like you said he's the
most decorated everyway champion he's
the most successful that success didn't
come from like not only his skillset but
also his mentality he has to go back
into the gym break that down take that
out of his game you know make that not
not a thing and also now he knows that
the it's the title is everything you
lose the title people don't even talk
about yeah they stop talking about him
yeah you know I felt obliged I felt like
I had an obligation to talk about steep
a I'm like no one's talking about him
like how are you not talking about the
most successful heavyweight champion of
all time yeah a guy who I understand him
having to have one fight before you
didn't rematch or he could he could have
legitimately just got the rematch
because of his resume as champion you
know I don't know III I don't like that
part of fighting where
you only as good as your last fight yeah
no I don't like it either I don't know I
just feel like I get the business aspect
of it I get that but I feel like what a
fighter like that you gotta give him a
rematch
you have to he deserves it he's a
chairman of like a legit champion the
guy says he wants a rematch set it up
[Applause]